if you want to do great things and you
need to be surrounded by greatness so
whether you're driving to work at your
office or doing personal chores at home
I hope you use this video as a
soundtrack to your life to help you go
out and accomplish something great today
when I started Microsoft I didn't think
of it as all that risky I mean I was so
excited about what we were doing
it's true I could have gone bankrupt but
you know I had a set of skills that were
highly employable and in fact my parents
were still willing to let me go back to
Harvard and finish my education if I
wanted to you've always got a job with a
bellman and the only the thing that was
scary to me wasn't quitting and starting
the company it was when I started hiring
my friends and they expected to be paid
and then we had customers who went
bankrupt customers that I counted on to
come through and so then I got this
incredibly conservative approach that I
wanted to have enough money in the bank
to pay a year's worth of payroll even if
we didn't get in heat any payments
coming in and I'm almost heard of that
the whole time we have about 10 billion
now which is pretty much enough for the
next year anyway you know I if you're
gonna start a company it takes so much
energy that you know you it better
overcome your your feeling of risk I
don't think that you necessarily if
you're gonna start a company should do
it at the start of your career I think
there's a lot to be said for working for
a company learning how they do things
you know if you're young it's hard to go
lease premises they made that hard for
me you couldn't rent a car when you were
under 25 at the time so I was always
taking taxis to go see customers and the
people would you know people say well
we're gonna go have a discussion in the
bar well I could go to the bar
and you know that's fun because I'll
tell you when people are first skeptical
and angle this kid doesn't know anything
then when you show them you've really
got a good product you know something
they actually tend to go overboard and
they think whoa
you know they know a lot let's really do
an incredible amount with these people
so our youth at least in this country
was a huge asset for us once we reached
a certain threshold it is hard it's hard
to hire old older people because they'll
be a little bit conservative about
whether they should come in and take the
risk and they took three or four years
before we could go out into the normal
sort of employment pool but those those
problems that come with starting the
firm you better think of those as as
part of the the pleasure part of the the
challenge that that is part of the the
excitement fundamental connection to
doing business is basically
relationships you know people really if
you really think about it people want to
do business with people they like I mean
every now and then you'll do a deal with
the devil but you don't really like the
devil but you have do it sometimes but
you really much rather do business with
somebody you like somebody who shares
your values somebody who you know is
committed to the same objectives you are
somebody's willing to work as hard as
you are and when you find those people
those are the people you want to bring
under your tent to be part of your
business objective and you've got to do
that by you know sort of presenting
yourself in a way that people clearly
understand that you are committed to
creating value business people want to
create value it doesn't mean they don't
want to have fun doesn't mean that they
don't want to be involved in other kinds
of things but if you can say go to
someone and convince them that I can
help you create value and by your
ability to articulate that and to
communicate it and to give people the
impression that you will work as hard as
they will to create that value you're
gonna find people wanting to come to you
and so from
it's sort of been like that throughout
my whole career is being able to to say
to people and what talk to people in a
way that convinces them that I am going
to do everything I can to help make what
they want to achieve a success and by
extension I'm going to be a success when
I started a bgt the guy who invested in
BET's a guy named John Maloney he was at
that time the operator the third largest
cable company in Denver Colorado and he
kept investing money and to be et
without taking additional equity and as
Beatty became a big success you know I
ended up with about 75% of the company
he ended up about 25% of the company and
one day I asked him when I say that John
John you you put over a half a million
dollars in BET's on the startup you put
it in his debt you didn't put it in his
equity which would have given him
greater ownership I said why'd you do it
that way and he said Bob I always knew
you would work harder for yourself than
you would for me and it was that kind of
commitment so if you can convey to
people that you're willing to work hard
for them and for yourself you've got a
business partner you're connecting the
dots well you get there through one
believing in yourself as you know so
well when we started we had $700 made a
day to day barely but we believe what we
did was the very very best and it goes
on the premise if you realize that
you're gonna run across a lot of
rejection I say this time in and time
out be prepared for the rejection no
matter how bad it is
don't let it overcome you or influence
you keep on going towards what you want
to do no matter what no matter whether
your bills are paid not paid someone
says no a thousand times again go back
to be as enthusiastic on door number 100
as you were on door number one but
believe in yourself and it's really all
about knowing you have a great service
or a great product that'll put you in
the reorder business so you're never
selling you're trying to get it in
someone's hands whether it's a service
or a product knowing it's so darn good
that they're gonna want to order it
again or tell a friend about it too
and that's the real secret there a lot
of us on the circumstances when they
starting with the ain't no plan B [ __ ]
got to work don't work what's gonna
happen you know so if you're in that
point in position you go what's working
and you start to get influenced so you
sway to what's actually working at the
moment and your music changes and starts
to sound a little bit like what's
happening on the radio it right now I've
heard demo tapes from ten different
little Wayne's there wasn't Lil Wayne
you know I mean I was like yeah that's a
down pat that's just sound like what you
do I did it stuff like how do you say
that it's not good if was working right
now is that you know I'm saying so you
go am I did it's good but it's hard for
me to really embrace it because you
ain't little Wayne what do you want me
to invest the money in at the copy
no she they don't work with it don't
ever let somebody tell you you can't do
something
not even me
all right
you got a dream
you got to protect it
people can't do something themselves
they want to tell you you can do it
you want something go get it period
I want to thank Harvard for this honor
I'll be changing my job next year and it
will be nice to finally have a college
degree on my resume I applaud the
graduates for taking a much more direct
route to your degrees from our my part
I'm just happy that the Crimson called
me Harvard's most successful dropout I
guess that makes me valedictorian of my
own special class I did the best of
everyone who fail
but I also want to be recognized as the
guy who got Steve Ballmer to drop out of
Business School
I'm a bad influence that's why I was
invited to speak at your graduation if
I'd spoken at your orientation fewer of
you might be here today one of the key
components of growing a business is
getting the necessary capital to grow so
if you start off where you own a hundred
percent but you need more capital to
grow the business you may have to sell
off 20% 30% depending on how you look at
the business needs don't fear that don't
don't be afraid about the notion that
you might fall below 51% and therefore
not be minority-owned because being
minority-owned is the culture you said
is the focus you said it's the service
you make to serve the minority community
and it's your commitment to do what you
can do best within the minority
community keep in mind if you go back to
a JPMorgan Chase Jamie Dimon probably
owns less than zero zero five percent of
chase he's the CEO because he yes but no
one ever questioned whether or not he's
in charge of chase but he's brought in
capital as a publicly traded company to
grow that business so whether you get
money from outside investors or whether
you get money from friends or family
don't be afraid to take on capital sell
[ __ ] sell shares or restructure debt or
treat preferred or common whatever it is
because the notion is you want to be in
charge of a growth company if that's
what you want to be a company that can
go to scale a company that compete and
you need capital to grow so don't if you
want to stay above 51% by all means if
you can do it and don't sell your equity
off do it but if you if you have to
because you got a great strategic
partner that could bring something to
the table and they want to be an equity
player
and you end up with 50 or for less than
50 you still the CEO you're still
setting the vision for the company you
are achieving what you set out to do and
I think that's very important to
understand because we can't get the
scale without growth capital I've been
homeless twice in my life when you're
down and out it's not an easy thing and
first time I was homeless I was 23 years
old second time is when I started John
Paul Mitchell Systems and I was in my
30s and started thinking how bad things
are and oh my god things are bad how do
I exist in this bad situation I looked
at how do I get out of it one time I had
no money had a car that our broken
radiator had to keep on putting water in
it but I would go around collecting old
soda pop bottles take him in two cents
for little one five cents for a big one
get some money and look for part-time
jobs no matter what they paid I wanted
to get out of it I didn't want to be
okay I'm gonna have to stay this way for
a while how do I survive I look at how I
got out of it and by gosh you can get
out of it America does work you just
have to do something I thought was ready
in 97 right and I didn't have a major
record company marking to promote my
project until 2003 all right you know so
for that time period I had to be running
on my own energy you know I had to
convince myself that I'm gonna make it
you know regardless of how people felt
at that time and what it does is it
makes you feel like what made me feel
like there's gonna be points that people
don't mistake my confidence for
arrogance because I've had they don't
understand the process I went through
mm-hmm and how much I had to believe in
myself in order to make these things
happen I kind of I feel like you can
will yourself into a good space things
that are meant to happen will and you
believe in yourself enough you can help
yourself learn you can inspire it you
know yourself in different ways where
you can actually discipline yourself you
know to the point that you can become
good enough like from 97 like when I
started writing it was full-time like
every day I was writing music because I
had no choice if I was gonna stop
hustling then how was I gonna provide or
create
the lifestyle that I created for my
son's mom my son and myself mm-hmm we
didn't grow up with the sense that where
we were was where we were going to be
you know we grew up with the sense that
where we were almost didn't matter
because we were becoming we were
becoming something greater I'm in
meetings a lot my Keller gets very full
with those and then at night after the
kids have gone to bed I'm on email a
great deal I get messages during the day
that's my chance to give long responses
and then over the weekend I send a lot
of mail as well as well I take two weeks
a year to just go off and read and think
where I'm not interrupted by work or
anything else I'm just solidly trying to
think about the future and people get to
send me things to read as part of that
so-called think week so it's nice mix of
things about 25% of the time that I'm
out traveling around meeting with
customers Europe Asia and that sort of
helps me think okay do we have the right
priorities what what are people
responding well to and what would they
they like to see us do better I may not
be smart but I'm not stupid so I got to
check first and then I said John I've
never started a business what advice can
you give me so but I had to check by
then he said Bob get your revenues up
keep your costs down okay that was my
501 business school class and ever since
that time every business I start
revenues up cost down that's what I do
all right thanks big business is where
you get your revenues up keep your costs
down and if you can find a recurring
income stream like a cable company
called BT the guys pay that cable
operators pay you for the programming
the advertisers pay you to advertise
within the program and the record
companies give you the videos free you'd
have to be pretty dumb to lose money on
a business like that so it's a
combination one the product but you
could also have the best product in the
world but unless you tell people about
and get them to use it it's just going
to sit there so is a combination of a
couple of things one that product was
exceptional same with
around Aquila's Paul Mitchell John Paul
pet exceptional product but then one
let's do what those that maybe aren't
quite as successful don't want to do
whatever it takes work seven days a week
from early morning till late at night a
lot of rejection comes your way overcome
that rejection and know that what you
have is so good eventually you'll get
through it eventually get the reorder
business I think the things you go
through make you who you are
I don't regret those things I don't
regret them because I don't think I'd be
Who I am today if I wasn't exposed to
those situations if you ask me would I
those are unfortunate situations that
I've had the experience and if I had a
choice I would have definitely went in a
different direction I might want want to
go to school for business instead of
having to go through that this portion
of my life there's a concept that I
don't want to be an icon I want to be an
idea you know I want to represent an
idea i want to represent possibilities I
want to represent magic right that
you're in a universe and two plus two
equals four
two plus two only equals four if you
accept it two plus two equals four two
plus two is gonna be what I want it to
be you know and there's that there's a
like there's that there's a redemptive
power that making a choice has you know
rather than feeling like you're at to
all the things that are happening make a
choice like you just decide what its
gonna be who you're gonna be how you're
going to do it just decide and then from
that point the universe is gonna get out
your way it's like its water it wants to
it wants to move and go around stuff you
know so for me I want to represent
possibilities I want to represent the
idea that you really can make what you
want one of my favorite books is the The
Alchemist Paulo Coelho and that's just I
just
believe that I believe that I can create
whatever I want to create if I can put
put my head on it right study it learn
the patterns and you know I just I it's
hard to put into where it's real
metaphysical esoteric nonsense but I
feel very strongly that we are who we
choose to be hello I'm Bill Gates
chairman of Microsoft in this video
you're going to see the future Windows
Microsoft first came up with the windows
concept back in 1983 and today the
leading software users have switched
into the Windows environment it's really
incredible how quickly our powerful
applications like Word and Excel and
PowerPoint have been adopted it's not
just Microsoft applications even
companies like WordPerfect and Lotus
have now come out with Windows
applications and every week we see new
innovative work it's really attracting
all the innovation in the industry we
predicted this a long time ago and now
it's the future the key to building
relationship and so-called connecting
the dots is make your friends before you
need them and that means that first
impression that first interaction you
have with somebody is sort of like a
stamp of approval and if you do that
with someone and they like you and then
they in turn tell somebody else they
like you that's where the dots start
coming because somebody will say I know
Dameon good guy so I respect the guy who
told me that too all of a sudden now
he's transferred his stamp of approval
on you over to me and that's what
happens successful people do the things
unsuccessful people don't want to do or
have a very difficult time doing guys
very difficult time and that is keeping
yourself going when nothing's working
when everyone else is saying no no
no-no-no no matter how much you feel
like you're prepared for something it
never happens on your time but when you
think you're ready like you're supposed
to happen it always happens when it's
supposed to happen because the period
did you feel ready and people are not
acknowledging the material the way you
feel like they should because it's good
is the time that you actually develop
skin thick enough to survive when it
does work the difference between
depression and joy right and I think
it's purpose right it's like when you
wake up in the morning and your life
means something to somebody other than
you that you have a purpose if you don't
go do the things that you're going to do
people's lives will suffer and I think
that that kind of purpose that like to
live in service not to you but to live
in service to humanity to live in
service to your family to live in
service to your church to your city to
your country to the world living in
service is that I feel like that is the
purest form of joy the key point there
is you've got to enjoy what you do every
day and for me that's working with very
smart people it's working on new
problems you know every time we think
hey we've had a little bit of success
we're pretty careful not to dwell on it
too much because the bar gets raised the
one thing I think we have to do is we've
got to get smart about consumption we
have got to start saving when I went to
graduate school at at Princeton and I
took one course in economics and there's
one term that I learned it's called and
you guys should remember this one it's
called the marginal propensity to
consume the marginal propensity to
consume is that you consume way beyond
your margin or wealth and you know what
they call that debt we have more debt
than any other group in America ergo we
have less
savings without savings you can't invest
without investment you can't accumulate
well we have got to postpone sort of
what I call just unnecessary impulsive
consumption and focus on savings and
until we get to that point we're not
going to have enough wealth to invest
first thing would be in your category
make it the best you possibly can so
when the end result is the consumer is
tasting it is it something they want to
get again that's number one
second thing is have a story or
excitement behind it which is true we
did that with patron for example we had
a tequila tasting test back in 1989 is
Spago's restaurant and we just want
hands down so there was some validity
not just from taste but from what was
going on but in any product let's say
you want to start an envelope company
Steve I think you come in anything you
have to know yourself that it's the best
you can do and then you have to be
willing to tell enough people until
enough people say yes once they say yes
you have to put your personality into it
go by and thank him make sure it's going
well a lot of people just shoot
something out to get can I get a
thousand customers where they have the
first 50 or 100 and don't pay attention
to them you must pay attention to your
first customers unreal attention it's
easier to keep somebody than this is try
and get somebody new yeah I'm not
interested in the financial coastal on a
continued success but there's no
specific mark
mmm-hmm finances that'll work because to
be honest with you if I'm sitting here
with you a year from now two years from
now and they like you did it you're a
billionaire imma still be saying it but
I got another idea right a new idea and
it's what I think is representation of a
person who was truly ambitious because
the ambition isn't a learned behavior
it's a part of your natural character
and you'll always find something to be
passionate about our new goal or
you see guys sell companies five six
billion dollars and go yeah okay now
what's the next one
greatness is not this wonderful esoteric
illusive godlike feature that only the
special among us will ever taste you
know it's something that truly exists in
all of us it's very simple this is what
I believe and I'm willing to die for it
you know
period it's that simple I Know Who I am
I don't know what I believe I know who I
am I know who what that's all I need to
know so from there you do what you need
to do you know and I think what happens
is we make the situation more complex
than it has because we're looking for
complexities got to be something complex
to understand it can't be that easy no I
love bridge bridge helps you think it's
a game you can play your entire life and
keep getting better and better I think
anybody is good at bridge it's gonna be
great a lot of things so I really
encourage people to get involved and I
want to thank the people who've put
things together for juniors they'll be
thanking you the rest of their life
because bridge is such great order as
most of you know I have always been
vocal about economic opportunity for
african-americans I'm what you might
call a serial entrepreneur I get a
vision about something that should be
done usually in an area where
african-americans are economically and
underrepresented and I try my best to
create a business solution to help
address these social and economic
problems do the best we can with what we
have see we want to live in the now and
usually when you're down and out or
having difficulties your mind is working
very fast not your being your mind is
working very fast and it's working off a
lot of nails from the past so a lot of
experiences from the past and worries of
what may happen the future going through
your mind well if you could eliminate
that by saying okay there's nothing to
do about the past that's done
yesterday's newspapers can't change them
and who knows for sure was could have in
the future let's
be here right now take what resources we
have right now act upon them and act
towards a good future goal so you are
actually going along the street trading
in you know bottles to get a nickel
apiece and in those days actually
actually was a second time I was also
it's okay but in those days you got two
cents for a little pop bottle five cents
for a big one in every grocery store and
every liquor store you would just bring
them to and they give you the money and
you know you do what you have to do
exist of if times are lean but alesis
nation affords that opportunity if you
know where you're at well how can I best
make it a survive not oh poor me how do
i entrench myself for long-term survival
it's how do I survive right now get
myself to the next step that's the
attitude you have to know I'm a rapper
entrepreneur a person that has doesn't
see limitations I have my person who has
high expectations for myself and when I
actually start to look at some of the
things that I've accomplished and I
become a little more interest in my
legacy like what people remember me as
is what made it more important that I
involved myself in philanthropy because
the people that resonate the strongest
in their absence have done more for for
people when they were actually in anger
positions the road to success is through
commitment and through the strength to
drive through that commitment when it
gets hard and it is gonna get hard and
you're gonna want to quit sometimes but
it'll be colored by who you are and more
who you want to be I definitely found
that wanting to be an actor stems from
wanting to be somebody and wanting to
say something to people I talked to my
dad I talked to Warren I had talked to
my wife Melinda so I I have enough
people that know me and actually know
where my judgment isn't its strongest
where I might get overexcited about
something or you know forget to think
about something
they're good at correcting picking lint
good at correcting whatever those blind
spots are and I think it's good to
encourage your friends and advisers to
really give them that license you know I
can go to a party and forget to say
hello to various people or something
that's a very minor example of my client
spots a small number of people that you
can turn to on on certain key things is
a great great asset people here in the
same business I mean if you're running
the same business or somebody else the
first thing I would do is sit down and
talk about can we merge and get the
scale that's the first thing I would do
there's no way in the world if I were
running a company let's say I was in the
security business providing security to
companies and then there's another guy
named Freddie who had a security company
and another guy named and a person named
Mary had a security come three security
companies all vying for the contracts I
would say why don't we merge get the
scale reduce our overhead costs and go
out and become the preeminent security
firm in the City of Charlotte there is
no way in the world I would be competing
against that that's the first thing I
would do for starters we know we have a
darn good product but if we take the
time with ourselves and our staff to go
in there and tell them all the ways to
use it and reassure them not as only a
good product but here's how you use it
to create a good salon experience or the
consumer when you take it home to keep
your hair the same in between visits you
fill a need in the marketplace one
there's the need of course to buy a
product or another product but the next
one is you must constantly remind them
how to use it properly which makes you a
little different now granted maybe
there's another one used the same way
but nobody told them we're at Mason
times when people are using some of our
finest products and didn't know there's
other ways to use that also it's through
education must constantly reinforce the
education and whites okay
and it's why I'm here there's nothing
that can actually compare
the one is right what it feels like when
when it's right
the music is just dead right and it's
like that energy that's dead manual
that's all it's a special kind of high
that you get addicted to and you chase
it for the rest of your actual career
when you feel that feeling what is your
first album second album third album
just a single because a lot of artists
have a career long enough for one song
you know but you feel what that feeling
is and you ain't gonna replace it the
only thing that that I can see and you
can never really look at yourself the
only thing that I see that is distinctly
different about me is I'm not afraid to
die on a treadmill right I will run it
would not be outworked I will not be be
outworked right period yeah you know you
might have more talent than me you might
be smarter than me you might be sexier
than me you might be all of those things
you got it on me in nine categories but
if we get on the treadmill together
right there's two things you're getting
off first yeah or I'm gonna die it's
really that simple right so let's go
back to the question about what if
people block me out it's do is going to
be two options yeah I'm gonna get back
in or I'm gonna be dead
Yeah right it's like you're not going to
outwork me it's a it's a very is such a
simple basic concept is the the guy who
was willing to hustle the most is gonna
be the guy that just gets that loose
ball you know you got the oh he got that
oh okay he got to oh god he's hustling
grabbed out my dad was going to be out
of bounds but he saved it back in it's
like the commodity that I see the
majority of people who aren't getting
the places they want or
aren't achieving the things that they
want in this business is strictly based
on hustle it's strictly based on being
out work is strictly based on missing
crucial opportunities I say all the time
if you stay ready you ain't got to get
ready my best business decisions really
have to do with picking people and
deciding to go into partnership with
Paul Allen is is probably at the top of
the list and then subsequently hiring a
friend Steve Ballmer and having somebody
who you totally trust who's totally
committed who shares your vision yet he
has a little bit different set of skills
and also acts as a check on you you know
some of the ideas you come up with you
run by them because you know they're
gonna say hey wait a minute yeah you
know have you thought about this and
that and just you know the the benefit
of sparking off of somebody who's who's
got that kind of brilliance it's not
only made it fun but it's really led to
a lot of success so picking picking a
partners is crucial you have to believe
in yourself if you don't believe in
yourself if you don't believe that you
can overcome obstacles if you don't
believe you have the work ethic if you
don't believe you have the inner
confidence to project to other people
it'll never happen because part of
starting a business is not having not
only having the vision of an idea you've
got to build around you a team of
stakeholders who believe in you people
follow leaders people invest in leaders
people support people who have a vision
and are willing to and are able to
articulate it and not just the ability
you know a lot of people could have got
a good gift for gab it's the ability to
convince people that you're gonna be
part of something that's going to be
successful you're going to share in the
success it's going to be beneficial to
you and your family in the long run
you're going to be respected for what
you contribute and you're going to have
an opportunity to fulfill your own
dreams
consistent with the dreams the person
you're working with if you can convey
that sense of confidence and that
consent because that sense of leadership
and focus on giving people an
opportunity to grow and be successful
with you you're gonna have people enemy
really smart people come in to be a part
of what you do I don't care what you
have in life no matter where you are in
your life they'll always be somebody
that needs it more than you do so
whenever you can give as little as it
might be or with us of your own self I
know my 20s in my early 20s I don't have
a lot of money but at Thanksgiving and
at Christmas I'd be in Griffith Park in
the lines at the feedin I'd be feeding
people they came in the line sir I was
there at the feed in I could serve
really good I could cut a turkey so cold
man I got really good at that I was a
good servant it made me feel good
because I was part of giving back as you
are part of giving back it opens you up
it opens you the human being up in a
huge way you was it your soul the entity
inside of you opens up it's the most
amazing thing it's not about poor me me
me me poor me i'ma get my look corner
over here poor me it's about
hey I'm gonna give I mean I have any
money but I'm gonna open that door for
you you need a helping hand I'm gonna be
there for you I'm gonna lend a helping
hand
your whole being opens up when things
like this happen we even brought it down
to the perspective of a person is in a
staff meeting that won't this is
watching someone else raise their hand
to answer a question that they know the
answer to and that means that person
deserves to be ahead of you in life
because your fear of being wrong at that
point is not allowing you to create your
value the separation of talent and skill
is one of the the the greatest
misunderstood concepts for people who
are trying to excel who have dreams that
want to do things talent you have
naturally skill is only developed by
hours and hours and hours of beating on
your craft there's no easy way around it
no matter how talented you are your
talent is going to fail you if you're
not skilled you know if you don't study
if you don't work really hard and
dedicate yourself to being better every
single day
you'll never be able to communicate with
with people I had one habit that I
developed when I when I was at college
it was actually very bad habit which was
I like to show people that I didn't do
any work and that I didn't go to classes
and I didn't care and then at the very
last minute like two days before the
test I get serious about it and and
people people thought that was funny you
know that was my positioning the guy who
did nothing until the last minute then
when I went into business that was a
really bad habit and it took me a couple
years to get over that nobody praised me
because I would do things at the last
minute and I tried to reverse to
students I'd actually I didn't think
that highly of who were always organized
and had things done on time I'm I'm
still working on it but procrastination
is not a good good habit bill can change
clothes in the car
imagine a group of people go to a
restaurant and they started well they
don't have enough money to pay the bill
so when the waiter comes with the bill
that they don't want to pay it they
don't make the sacrifice of pay so they
keep ordering and that's what we're
doing we just keep piling on debt and
keep piling on costs because we don't
want to make the hard choices when we
hire people at patron or John Paul
Mitchell Systems the people we hire do
more than one thing we purposely give
someone the responsibility of several
positions they're paid extremely well we
take more than good care of them but it
gives them the opportunity to be in
something that times are ever tough you
don't have to eliminate anybody they can
migrate into a variety of things because
they're already doing it now as business
thinks about this and they start hiring
people from beginning with fewer moving
parts we probably have one-fourth the
amount of staff that our competitors
have you know per capita and per you
know what we do in business but we hire
will you do more than one thing in fact
I think it's one of the things that's
going to make America great it made
America great in the past it hasn't been
quite as great as it could be but it
will be in the future
we're
instead of getting one job to do one
thing all the time that they draw it out
because it gets so boring they do two or
three things all of a sudden they're
happy what they're doing they're excited
about it and their day is full guys this
is crazy I grew up without money but I
didn't grow up hungry what's going on in
this world out of control I mean there's
so many people suffering from hunger
I mean dying from hunger every day I
went to Africa and the devastation I
witnessed changed me forever I mean you
see people who don't know when they're
gonna see their next meal or if they
don't receive their next meal it's crazy
I want to feed a billion hungry people
and I need your help to do that this is
our world these are streets
I need your energy let's do this I'm
motivated by fear fear you know fear of
what fear of fear I hate being scared to
do something I hate that feeling of the
feeling that I had before I had a
meeting with Quincy Jones because it's
really Quincy Jones and a guy named
Benny Medina who I know and Jeff Pollan
came with the idea for the Fresh Prince
of bel-air and I hated being scared you
know like that I didn't want to even
take the meeting there were there were
opportunities during when I first my
first year as a rapper Bill Cosby and
the people in The Cosby Show had seen my
music video and called me to be a
character to come right and try out for
the Cosby Show and just every time it
was set up for some reason I couldn't
make it the fear of theá-- the fear I
hated I just hated that being scared to
do something and I think what developed
in my in my early days was the the
attitude that I started attacking things
that I was scared some challenge
partner in Facebook's Sheryl Sandberg
and Netflix is founder and CEO Reed
Hastings I'm glad to give to ALS it's a
great cause but I want to accept this
challenge I want to do it better than
it's been done been working on this you
know got this design there we go
yeah it's gonna be great
I'm here to join the people bringing
attention to Lou Gehrig's disease by
taking the ALS ice bucket challenge I'm
gonna challenge three more people Elon
Musk Ryan Seacrest and Chris Anderson of
Ted
consider yourself challenged you have 24
hours
good luck
is it true that you can leap over a
chair from a standing position it
depends on the size of the chair I'll
cheat a little bit
by the way I believe in winners and
losers and especially the freedom to
fail
Oh
look at businesses who have who can
provide support to your business at a
cost below what you're paying somebody
else and if you don't have the money to
for that but it'll help you jump-start
your business give them equity trade
equity for the service provider it
happens all the time
when I start a BT I need a cable
distribution some of the cable Time
Warner at that time said yeah we'd like
to be an investment but we also want
equity we'll give you our carry but we
want equity and that's another way to
build a relationship doesn't take
capital just you gotta be half confident
but when you provide a service that
service is gonna help this business grow
Europe 10% equity whatever the trade is
help you grow long term entrepreneurship
is liking what you do who you do it with
and who you do it for if you're not
having fun then you're only in business
to make some money I still work I work
every single day but I love what I do
SIA fund so it became a lifestyle when
you're working it becomes work it's not
fun when you're working becomes part of
your lifestyle because you like it it's
fun I look forward to calling on salons
I look forward to walking in some places
say thank you for using Paul Mitchell I
look forward to walking into a cocktail
lounge Wow thank you for having patron
on the menu to people in the hip-hop
industry thank you for singing about
patron in the country western history
thank you for doing this in other words
I like it so much that I appreciate so
much also the people that like it too
it's a lifestyle and it's a good one so
if an entrepreneur can make a lifestyle
that they like with the people they want
to deal with part of their business
it'll be long term and it will prosper
because you are having fun every once
that funny
I just wanna thank everybody showing the
support
so that was
yesterday I listened to Fat Joe's record
she's hurt
and I told you people
not to listen to his music and some
people didn't listen young motorcycle
after this is ready
skateboarded we will ride a bike all
over the places people playing the music
try to work out I just plug in the worst
feel and it hurts bad look good I love
him all the world to say I beat
everywhere please it is because this
music sucks so bad
gonna kill people listen to it please
you think I'm gonna make it man I
probably won't make it faster for you
baby I'm a hole up kid don't take me
with you
[ __ ] fortune
and he's off
we're talking about film you've got a a
big big big film coming out very soon
yeah did a project man look I did a big
one you did a real big one yeah
and over you are my shadow it's been
following me ever since I was smaller
the story you know
don't be afraid
the villain eat don't
I've been shot nine times I'm not afraid
in a little white girl
you a better man than me
you happy now you're gonna tell will or
not I'm not gonna do your dirty work for
you fine I'll call him from the road
yeah then why don't you do this Daniela
what's that we'll glad you hear some
business came up I got a handle so we're
gonna have to put a our trip on hope you
understand yeah yes that's cool just for
a couple of weeks mmm I understand hit
it maybe a little longer yeah whatever
whatever look I'll call you next week
and we'll iron out the details okay yeah
yeah it was great seeing you son you too
Lou
yeah
I'm sorry will you know what actually
this works out better for me you know
this slimmies the summer come to class
wearing that's nuttin you know well it's
all right to be angry
hey why should I be mad for saying at
least he said goodbye this time I just
wish I hadn't wasted my money buying a
stupid present I'm sorry I'd you know if
there was something that I hey you know
what you ain't gonna do no no Phil hey
you know ain't like I'm still 5 years
old you know
ain't like imma be sittin up every night
asking my mom when's daddy coming home
you know who needs him he wasn't there
to teach me how to shoot my first basket
but I learned didn't I
hey I got pretty damn better too didn't
I got through my first day without him
right I learned how to drive I learn how
to shave I learned how to fight without
him I had 14 great birthdays without him
he never even sent me a damn car I need
him then and I'll need him now will now
you know what Uncle Phil let me get
through college without him I'm gonna
get a great job without him I married me
a beautiful honey and I'm having a whole
bunch of kids I'll be a better father
than he ever was and I sure as hell
don't need him for that cuz ain't a damn
thing he could ever teach me about how
to love my kids how come you don't want
me man
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I love to know what you
think of the video if you want to leave
a comment below continue to believe and
I'll see you soon